We've talked about using
intents within Sunshine
to start activities
and send data between apps.
But what if you want to broadcast
a message to many apps?
For example, the system will broadcast
a message, saying that
the device is charging
or that it's just finished rebooting.
To do that ourselves,
we use the SendBroadcast method
to broadcast an intent.
And those broadcasts are recieved
by broadcast receivers, typically referred
to as, simply, receivers.
Using intent filters,
like the ones we saw earlier,
they indicate which broadcast
they're interested in.
So if we return to our envelope
metaphor from earlier,
in the case of a broadcast intent,
your envelope is basically addressed
to any broadcast receiver
that's interested in knowing
that this event has happened.
And it does that using intent filter.
So intents, which are broadcast,
are transmitted to every app
with a broadcast receiver
that has an intent filter
telling the system
your ideas are intriguing
to me and I wish
to subscribe to your newsletter.